the villain Muse has been announced as
the main villain for Daredevil Born
Again In the MCU so we're going to cover
the story with him so this opens up
basically with just a gigantic mural on
a wall and initially it doesn't seem
like that big of a deal right it seems
pretty innocuous but what we find out
right off the bat from Daredevil is that
this entire mural is painted in blood
now there's just this guy right who's
just laying there next to the whole
thing something I do also want to point
out for a second is that there's a kid
here who's named blind spot right his
name is technically Sam Chung and he
actually wears a suit that's battery
power that allows him to go invisible
he's kind of like a sidekick to
Daredevil if there was such a thing in
this day and age but the fact remains
like Sam doesn't really understand how
dark things can be when it comes to the
world of Daredevil because when you're
talking about street level villains
right guys like jigsaw you know
Tombstone Lonnie different things like
that you're talking about some some
pretty hardcore villains who do some
pretty hardcore stuff but even Daredevil
himself hasn't seen anything like this
because normally villains are fairly
two-dimensional they want money or power
or something like that but it's like
Michael Kane said some men just want to
watch the world burn and so while
they're talking about calling the cops
which of course they do the question
that's asked by blind spot is how much
blood do you think it took to make this
and that's where Daredevil kind of
sniffing around realizes that not all
this blood comes from the same person
and he realizes it actually comes from
at least
113 people now at that point you switch
over to What's called the deran gallery
and in fact it's kind of this Gallery
that's done based on the painting and
all that kind of stuff where the general
public can come and see it and Court put
a gag order in place that kept it from
happening and so on and so forth the
people who did it will become important
later on in the story at least
relatively important but what is
important here is once they get to the
mural the whole thing's been painted
over with the words you're only as good
as your last performance and an address
right this is an invitation because what
it does is it leads to Matt Murdoch and
it leads to Sam basically you know
getting a police escort getting to that
location in the Bronx and when they get
there there's a whole bunch of Inhumans
that are all dead now this takes place
following inhumanity and for those of
you guys who were unfamiliar with that
during the events of Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers blackbolt got
absolutely dominated by Thanos which
makes perfect sense because blackbolt
sucks but prior to that point blackbolt
had detonated something called the ter
bomb and we ended up learning that
secretly all across earth were all these
Inhumans that nobody knew about and so
these all started activating and so on
and so forth the fall out of that came
Post Secret Wars going into all new all
different Marvel even continuing here
which is that all these in humans just
kind of exist out there in different
capacities some join the royal family
out in N tillan which nobody knows why
You' want to do that and then some
decide to stay out here what's going on
is that this guy right Muse basically
has killed these Inhumans and in turn
positioned them as almost kind of
caricatures performing mundane tasks and
that's what's so crazy about it is what
we're going to find is this guy does
this as a kind of work of art because
even this shows just kind of the mundane
nature of life people just doing things
that people do because we're people and
that's just what we do right and so
that's one of the crazy things is
because Sam's never seen anything like
this so it totally blows his mind and
even Matt Murdoch right seeing his besti
can is pretty Blown Away by all of it
but for those of you guys who are
familiar with Daredevil this guy's
always paying attention to what goes on
around him right it's second nature just
kind of him being on the streets for so
long so on and so forth and so what he
does is he picks up a heartbeat and the
heartbeat has a bit of a flutter a
nervous heartbeat and he realizes
someone's watching so he asked the
question of one of the cops right he's
like are there any private spots around
here and this guy says sure the whole
building's vacant the owner just
finished a big renovation he was
planning to start leasing the floors
next month just pick a floor and so Matt
Murdoch goes to the rooftop and as he
follows this heartbeat right it gets
louder and louder the closer he gets he
finally comes face to face with Muse the
first question this guy asks do you like
my work now what's crazy about this is
that we get this kind of perception of
muse from Matt Murdoch's Viewpoint to a
degree in the sense that this guy kind
of operates like a Vortex right and what
we're literally told sense sounds it's
like he's drawing them into himself like
a black hole of sensory information and
what it does is just kind of disrupts
the nature of Matt Murdoch's Powers
right because remember echolocation
using his different senses to compensate
for his blindness in order to kind of
quote unquote see everything around him
and so this is right off the bat a
weakness that Matt Murdoch has he can't
directly see this guy and so what you
get is this conversation between the two
of them where Matt Murdoch ask the
question who are you right and that's
the cool thing this is like this is why
I love the character of muse right he
says haven't you seen the papers they're
calling me Vincent Van Gore I don't like
that though it's low undistinguished
I've been toying with the name Muse but
that could change reinvention is one of
the keys to a long career because what
this guy does is just kind of fall rank
file with the nature of people who
commit these kinds of crimes it's one of
the reasons why like whenever you see
movies and I don't know if it really
happens in the real world but they'll
put out a kind of name for this person
that they will take offense to and it's
an effort to draw them out or to get
them to create more you know Reckless
crimes and make it easier to find them
of course by doing that you willingly
more or less sacrifice people but you
know at the end of the day I guess
that's just a price that cops are
willing to pay I don't really know but
this guy he says don't make beg tell me
if you liked my work and that's when
Matt Murdoch begins to kind of put it
all together and he's like the people
you murdered like what is like what what
kind of work is that supposed to be and
the thing that Muse responds with is he
says murder that's a funny little word
is it murder if the person wants to die
I don't think so I think that's a gift
and it creates this really interesting
moral philosophy if a person wants to
die is it really considered murder of
that person right I mean I guess
according to the court systems sure but
what about that person's agency right
what about their desire to no longer
live do they have no real ability to
influence that or do we just kind of
handwave the ideology that well they're
not uh they're they're not rational
they're not sound because no rational
sound person would do that for no other
reason than the fact that we as people
have just kind of shoulder shrug decided
that and so it's one of those really
interesting moral quandaries that sort
of comes in with a character like him
but at the end of the day he realized
okay Matt doesn't like it he's like then
my next work will be better and so when
Matt asks like why are you doing this
like why are you killing he says I am an
artist my friend and as an artist I hold
to a strict code never explain and never
apologize for example then he pops a
grenade and Matt Murdoch immediately
bails this guy just flees for his life
the whole thing goes off and that
Murdoch realizes there's no heat and no
pressure it was likely a flashbang it's
not a real thing and so following that
he basically picks up with a phone call
that comes from Sam and the reason why
is because the next day Sam contacts him
because basically this guy Muse has
shown up in a courtroom right and he
literally says do you like my knife I
carved it myself I believe you can find
beauty inside just about anything for
instance my knife was once inside a
woman named Carolyn Stringer not a very
attractive lady it has to be said but
just look at her now and so it's one of
those things where he sees himself as
improving there right it's like uh what
is it red dragon right like Mrs leads
evolving do you see like it's that kind
of thing right so again a very twisted
and screwed up perspective but he's not
your normal run-of-the Mill villain
right which just makes him so cool
because one of the cops jumps up points
a gun at him and says lose the knife
he's like sure thing and like throws the
knife at the guy hits him right in the
throat so it's just like dang dude this
guy is dope right immedi he grabs the
judge and bails Sam jumps after him the
whole time he's on the phone with Matt
Murdoch right and like literally Matt's
just like I heard a scream what happened
and he's like Muse right he killed a cop
and then he ran he took the judge he was
so fast Daredevil it all happened so
fast I didn't even have time to move and
where Daredevil asked the question where
is he now where is Muse the response is
Sam I don't know but I will and so what
you do is you get to the outside and
literally it's just like all these cops
outside the courtroom right SWAT the
whole nine yards right let the hostage
go we can talk about this right his
response oh no I'm not much of a talker
it's something to notice here this guy
doesn't panic this guy doesn't get
overwhelmed now that's kind of like a
Hallmark of just like being a psychopath
or a sociopath sure you feel emotions
but for the most part in moments when
like you're actually bringing harm to
people what you're doing doesn't really
matter to you in reference to like how
it affects the other person it's
irrelevant right so the fact that he's
surrounded by cops and all these people
have guns pointed out and M is kind of
like I mean I'm not really much of a
talker you know it's not really my thing
and he says I prefer to let my work
speak for me and what he does is he
pulls out a Detonator because the guy
had rigged the court to blow the entire
Courthouse he rigged the whole thing
right detonates it all it all goes off
right one of the cops requesting back up
emt's and bomb squad to Center Street
right Daredevil's on his way out there
as fast as he possibly can beaten feet
while all that happens literally Muse
just grabs the judge and Baals in the
sewers and then in turn Sam goes after
him all the while on the phone with Matt
and Matt says do not go down there if
you do I'll end up losing contact with
you now for Matt Murdoch this is a big
deal because Sam is untrained this is a
guy who has joined alongside Matt
Murdoch on his journey but doesn't
realize how hard and fast things can get
and how dark and screwed up they can get
and so what you do is you switch over to
things from Sam's perspective right he's
like why did I say that I'm not letting
him kill anybody else who do I think I
am I just want to impress Daredevil it
sounded like something that he would say
and he says do I really mean it how far
will I actually take this so he's kind
of figuring out his role of a superhero
as he goes through all this stuff and
even then like when Muse lays the judge
down he sits him around all the other
people that he's kidnapped and he simply
says time to create and so we get this
really cool explanation here as he's
talking to all of them right he says
ultimately though this will be my work
you should know that I consider you to
be essential parts of the team I
couldn't realize my vision without each
and every one of you do you think the
symbolism here is too overt a judge a
politician and two cops the entire legal
system start to finish more specifically
councilwoman Pearson officer Scott and
Menendez and of course judge lar the
four members of the legal system who
conspired to shut down the Public's
access to my beautiful blood mural these
are the ones specifically the
councilwoman and the judge who issued
the order to shut down the Public's
access to his mural right he takes
personal offense to it and so of course
he rolls out his tool kit right his bag
of goodies and he says so I thought
present the work down here with
everything else that's gone down the
toilet symbolism is tricky it's a fine
line too little and no one gets the
point too much and it's just obvious art
should never be obvious so again this is
one of the coolest things about him
right when you look at deevil villains
especially somebody like Bullseye as
awesome as Bullseye is and as
ridiculously underrated and
underutilized as he is in Marvel Comics
he's still basically your
run-of-the-mill villain outside of
stories like Shadowland right where he
just fought an Army of Ninjas by himself
which technically should just simply be
impossible because the hand are an
almost indestructible ninja Clan even
looking at guys like Kingpin who almost
kind of seem larger than life they're
still basically run-of-the-mill seeking
power seeking recognition seeking fame
this guy is just kind of wanting to
create art he considers himself an
artist and he wants the world to see the
the work that he's cre creating but he's
not really doing it with a clear message
it's not as though he's telling them you
guys represent corruption and I'm going
to show Society what corruption it's not
really anything like that right for him
he's just performing what he considers
to be art and he says that said you guys
are not the public you're part of the
work so it's important that you
understand the intent of all of this I
think it will help inform your stylistic
choices as we move forward and he says
oh I don't know I just don't no I feel
like I'm missing something this is a
challenging piece I have to tell you and
so what he does with his knife he just
grabs one of the cops and cuts their ear
off and he was like yeah sometimes
that's just the only way to approach
something like this sometimes you just
need to start cutting and that's when
Sam shows up literally saves these guys
on the spot right and so what this guy
really what new realizes is this guy's
the missing piece right like the legal
system is only one part of the equation
right right we have superheroes so I
need a vigilante somebody that
represents modern Justice right and
that's when he decides to go after Sam
now for his part for his part as
untrained as Sam is and is in over his
head as he is he actually plays it
pretty intelligently right dodging
bobbing and weaving using his suit to
make himself invisible getting out of
the way of muse hiding out different
things like that right using the Shadows
to his Advantage the guy pulls it off
incredibly well because what he does is
he literally leads Muse on a merry Chase
and then doubles back goes back to the
hostages and cuts them free so it's like
this is really really smart I was
impressed I was like dude this guy I
love the way he's written here like it's
solid and he even tells them like I'm
GNA get you guys out of here the whole
time right like Ms is just screaming at
him like there's no way blind spat
you're not going to allow it right you
belong to me now little man and and that
sort of thing and as making their way
through the tunnels because the judge
and because you know the council woman
never come down here right they're
rarely even ever on the street level and
if they are is because they're traveling
from one Ivory Palace to the next right
so it's just things they observe but
don't really see themselves as being a
part of they don't know how to get out
of here so fortunately for blind spot
he's able to kind of help them get out
because if he wasn't here and they were
to somehow free themselves on their own
I mean it'd be fish in a barrel right I
mean there'd be no way they'd make it
out of here in one piece and so by
getting them all like pointing them to
safety and telling them where to go he
doubles back again and then allows Muse
to kind of follow him around in order to
offer himself as a distraction while the
others get away the problem with this is
that partway through his battery dies
and so he comes to the realization that
if he stays down here he could just kind
of move through the sewers and maybe
he'll survive maybe he won't but
Daredevil will never find him so he
crawls up one of the ladders opens a
manhole calls Daredevil and leaves his
phone sitting there so Daredevil at
least knows he was down in the sewers
when he was last seen at that point Matt
Murdoch is incensed one part because
this guy Muse of course in his mind is a
criminal and needs to be dealt with but
twoo he's made it personal by going
after someone that Matt Murdoch cares
about the other part of this is guilt
that Matt Murdoch bringing Sam on told
him not to necessarily get involved but
maybe there was something more he could
have done right that kind of situation
and that's when we really get this kind
of clear recognition of the weakness
that Daredevil has when it comes to Muse
the fact that this guy sucks in all the
sensory information around him makes it
impossible for Daredevil to locate him
but that's when Daredevil switches it on
his head right he's like okay if this
guy is a black hole of information then
stop looking for information and look
for where there's no information look
for where I can't see right a blind spot
a hole out there in the city somewhere
when he does that he tracks this guy
down now what you do is you switch back
to Muse Wally has blind spot and this is
where things get brutal because he drops
them off and I feel like we get just
this perfect understanding of muse more
so than we have before right he says
welcome to my Garrett blind spot every
starving artist should have one now
technically you shouldn't see any of
this it's a real look behind the curtain
there's this Mystique about art a shared
fiction if you will an artist presents a
piece to the world in its finished form
and pretends that it's simply appeared
that way effortlessly birthed from his
genius both artist and audience prefer
to believe that's the truth it's nice to
think that the really good creators have
some direct connection to the Divine but
it's a lie it's a really really cool
Point that he's making here because he's
kind of drawing this comparison between
like artistry and magic and depending on
who you're talking to some will say that
it's one and the same right you have an
audience who's sitting there watching a
person perform magic they want to be
tricked they want to believe that
there's something greater going on here
than a person hiding a card up their
sleeve that there's just something they
don't know some kind of of Supernatural
element there they know there's not but
they want to believe there is and so he
says in reality it's hours and hours of
missteps frustration and bad ideas that
gets sliced away to reveal some kind of
truth it's never easy in fact it's Agony
and removing this guy's blindfold inside
this Warehouse is just absolute Madness
human brains body parts the whole nine
yards it's one of just the darkest
things that I think I've ever seen and
he says so what do you think of course
Sam responds you don't have to do this
and this is where we get this awesome
explanation right he says wow man don't
you think I told myself that and he says
after that first one it was a woman just
someone I picked up I made her into
something abstract told myself I
shouldn't that it was wrong but it
didn't feel wrong the truth is kid when
I'm making I'm strong I am right but
people don't really understand what I do
they object to my preferred medium if
you get my meaning I only have so much
time to work before someone managed just
to stop me I need to use every moment so
yes blind spot I have to do this if I
don't who will so it's almost kind of
like this Joker type concept with his
character right and he's like what's
caught your eye down there do you see
something that you like and he says oh
yeah tin fingers I liked him thought he
had potential and he did as you can see
right so it's just kind of using people
and not really even seeing them as
people he doesn't see anybody out here
as people he sees them as the
eventuality of his art pieces and really
nothing more because he literally says
that right he became art just like the
people who contributed their blood to my
Singularity piece and so in the midst of
this whole conversation right he tells
Sam like the question to ask is what am
I going to make out of you and that's
when Daredevil pops up and Daredevil is
forced to watch as Muse says okay sure
whatever and then he says you know
I think I just figured it out suddenly
I'm feeling inspired and when he says
that he plunges his fingers into the
eyes of Sam and blinds him right and
Daredevil's just like no right he's like
forced to watch this and the response of
muse you see it don't you blind spot
right it's beautiful and throws them off
a ledge right throws Sam off the ledge
this guy's just the most callous
sadistic psychopath that I think has
ever been introduced in a daredevil
comic but it's written so well that it
almost kind of makes you want to cheer
for the bad guy even though you know
you're not supposed to and so what Sam
does is he tells Daredevil something
that MW said he still has the people
here the ones he took for the blood
mural I think they're still alive and
he's like don't let anyone else die so
Matt Murdoch chases this guy down and
when he gets to him what he realizes is
that the mural that was painted in the
beginning yes it was the blood of 113
people but they're not all dead they're
being drained for their blood they've
just been snatched up by Muse at some
point just missing persons and they're
all just hanging upside down dripping
into a bucket it is crazy right and so
you have Muse again just very Cavalier
very just Devil May care and he says why
do you care about these people don't you
realize they're better off their lives
mean something now it doesn't matter if
they die here they're Immortal and then
he's like you know what you just
wouldn't understand and then he just
cuts the Rope right and all these people
are getting ready to plunge to their
deaths and so Matt Murdoch is able to
basically lock down this device and keep
all these people from falling but his
concern is he's going to lose Muse in
the process the funny thing about this
is once Muse gets to the rooftop all
these cops are waiting on him and so
Matt Murdoch approaches him and Muse
kind of Beats him to the punch right
he's like yo here I think I can help and
he breaks his own fingers right he's
like this is what you were looking to do
right something like this make it
impossible for me to create art ever
again and he's like don't worry I'm
happy to do it it's better for the story
right because these art pieces that I've
made I can never duplicate I can never
do it again now they're one of a kind
right my story is singular
self-contained never to be duplicated in
any way way and so Matt Murdoch asks him
he says what are you and he pulls his
mask off only for us to end up seeing
this extremely twisted and pretty
disfigured face and he's like I'm just a
man and a mask nothing more than that
and that's what so cool is because you
almost kind of get this idea that like
there's almost something Supernatural
about this guy something Beyond normally
human but the reality is we don't know
his name and there is nothing special
about him he's just a man in a mask and
that's basically it so of course Sam is
effectively carted off and that sort of
thing and taken to the hospital where
he's left to recover and of course
Daredevil tells him that he saved all
the people who were basically injured
that kind of thing and so the response
to Sam is like well you know it was
worth it losing my eyesight but the
reality here is this guy is seemingly
down for the count but that's the story
of muse guys let me know what you think
about him down in the comments section
and does this story make you excited to
see him in Daredevil because it does for
me but we're going to bring this to an
end thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later peace